ashani and minari are trying to stay on
top of their schoolwork
the sisters who attend a government
school in colombo have public exams in a
few months
but their teachers have stopped
conducting online classes as part of a
trade union action demanding better pay
it's difficult to study the syllabus by
ourselves there's a lot to cover
especially with the final exams coming
the girl's mother sita works as a maid
three days a week their father is a
builder
they say they cannot afford to pay
private tuition for any of their four
children
it's families like us day wage earners
that are the worst affected we only have
school or online classes to rely on
that's why we're worried
sri lanka's ceylon teachers union is on
an indefinite strike which keeps them
away from online teaching exam
preparation paper correction and other
duties
it says 25 years of waiting for better
pay is more than enough
the lowest paid teachers in south asia
are in sri lanka this is truly an
embarrassing situation india salaries
are more than double those paid here we
say increase our salaries immediately
the government won't do anything about
it we will continue our struggle till
they do
successive reviews have agreed that the
salary disparity between teachers and
other government employees must be
addressed
but the government says teachers will
have to wait for the proper procedure to
get the wage hike
the procedure is the budget we've
already begun to make plans to present
the necessary documents as part of the
budget this issue has to be resolved
through the budget and be presented in
that framework
but the teachers are not buying it they
say the government is spending millions
of dollars on unnecessary projects and
can easily sort out the teacher salary
issue if there is a will to do so
recent weeks have seen some of the
largest demonstrations by the 250 000
strong union
heavy-handed police action during the
coronavirus pandemic to arrest and
quarantine protesters has drawn
criticism from the teachers and
affiliated trade unions
the government is trying to suppress us
we will not be coward and we will take
our struggle forward
while the government fights teachers on
salary differences that have lasted for
decades students in over ten thousand
government schools like the one behind
me bear the brunt of the work stoppage
students like ashani and minari will be
hoping the strike will be over soon so
they can carry on with their studies
milo fernandez al jazeera colombo